[Music]
static shock returns to television a
secret crossover with barbie what
mysteries are hiding in the dreams of
the sandman
when we first meet johanna constantine
she's on her way to a church for some
light exorcism under the pretext of
officiating a clandestine wedding when
she arrives instead of marrying the
couple she speaks a latin incantation
that forces a demon from the possessed
groom things get messy from there once a
demon erupts from the man he possessed
dream arrives and identifies him as
agalayath before dream can get the
information he needs johanna completes
her spell and forces the demon back to
hell much to our main character's
annoyance
agaleath doesn't appear in the sandman
comics but fans of john constantine may
recall him from hellblazer number 196.
in that issue john is deeply unfocused
after recovering from being hypnotized
and he's unable to recover his memories
he stumbles upon a horrific scene when
demons sit around a table eating people
at the head of the table is rosacarnis
who welcomes him but agalayath has other
ideas
he stands defying jon despite his host's
insistence to sit down
rosacarnis rips the demon apart from the
inside destroying him at john's feet
one of the recurring themes of the
sandman is that everyone gets a single
life to live and then they die and move
on for some it's hell for others it's
the silver city those are two examples
of many as far as the dreaming is
concerned when a person dies there they
can become a raven as demonstrated by
matthew but there are exceptions
hobgatling lucked into immortality by
becoming the focus of a bet between
dream and death but he's not the only
immortal human in the series another
immortal soul is seen briefly in episode
3 and that would be mad heady she meets
johanna constantine and tells her that
morpheus has returned he's no fairy
story missy he's fat and he wants his
son most viewers probably wondered who
this woman is and how she could know
anything about morpheus activities matt
heady is actually more than 200 years
old born in 1741 and like mr gatling she
didn't think dying was all that
interesting to prospect to avoid her
eventual demise she hid her heart from
death literally she's been labeled a
witch over the years and does know some
basic magic she pops up occasionally to
interact with john constantine just as
she does with his female counterpart in
the sandman series other than offering
up her incredible age she tends to keep
her most important secrets to herself
when the corinthian leaves jed in the
hotel room in episode 9 jed is watching
cartoons on television on the screen a
few characters flash by revealing that
he's enjoying an episode of static shot
called toys in the hood in the episode
the toy man arrives in static's home
town of dakota and attempts to capture
darcy this is important because darcy is
an android created by the toy man
however she seems to have developed a
mind of her own and distances herself
from the creepy nerd well after toy man
successfully abducts darcy static goes
searching for her he's soon joined by
superman and the two team up for the
episode it doesn't take long for the
heroes to learn that the toy man's plot
isn't what it appears his true motive is
to capture static's friend daisy the toy
man and darcy plan to use daisy's body
as a template so that the android can
become human several elements of the
cartoon align with jed's story in the
sandman like daisy jed is caught between
two powerful forces on the one side the
manipulative corinthian hopes to use jed
for his nefarious purposes and on the
other stands jed's sister rose and her
friend gilbert the two are working
together to try and save jed of course
there's more going on but the crux of
the static shock episode parallels the
events of the episode
as dream and matthew are escorted
through hell they happen upon a woman
locked inside a cage when dream caesar
the two have a short conversation and
it's clear from their talk that they
have a long history dream who nada knows
as kai cool reveals that they haven't
seen each other in 10 000 years she begs
for dream to free her but he's not yet
ready
i still love you
i have not yet forgiven you
his response is chilling and taken
directly from the comics the scene will
leave viewers wondering how morpheus
could be so callous to a woman he loves
but there is an explanation nada's
damnation came about following a brief
affair between her and the dream lord
she tracked dream to the dreaming and
confessed her love for him but fled
after discovering that he was an endless
filled with passion dream followed her
to the waking world and rekindled her
affection while making love on a hill
outside her city a meteorite slams into
her home destroying everyone and
everything the devastation consumes
natan she commits suicide before dream
can stop her morpheus follows her into
the afterlife and asks her to return
with him after refusing twice he tells
her if she does it again he'll damn her
to hell when she does eventually dream
comes to terms with nana's actions after
an ordeal with a demon and places her
soul in a newborn baby then he tells
nada she can return to the dreaming
whatever she wishes
when rosa's abilities as a dream vortex
begin to manifest she finds herself
inside the dreams of her friends who
live with her in a quaint house in
florida each of the residents dreams is
important to the story but one stands
out from the rest her friend barbie's
dream seems to have a long history
filled with familiar characters and a
developing story in the dream barbie is
on a quest with a traveling companion
called martin tenbones who mentions
something called the porpentine assuming
the show stays true to the comics this
should become important to the story
following the events of the sandman
season 1. barbie's dream martin ten
bones and the porpentine all set up the
comic's arc titled a game of you the
fairy tale-like environs of barbie's
subconscious are layered with complexity
and go back to her childhood she dreams
of a magical world called the land where
she's a deposed princess fighting
against the evil abstract being known as
the cuckoo as barbie matures her dream
continues but everything falls apart
after she witnesses her husband ken
having sex with a dream woman barbie
eventually moves to new york city where
she no longer dreams leaving the land in
disarray as the land crumbles martin ten
bones breaks into the waking world
looking for barbie's help perhaps we'll
see this story line in future seasons of
the show
janet coleman's casting is johanna
constantine is a change from the source
material as she replaces john
constantine from the comics they're more
or less the same character and coleman
plays a perfectly damaged supernatural
sleuth if you enjoyed seeing her as
johanna constantine in the third episode
it's something of a treat to see her
return in the sixth as lady johanna
constantine her 18th century ancestor
she and her band of ruffians threaten
morpheus and are quickly dispatched
later morpheus mentioned seeing her once
more explaining that she's completed a
task for him constantine will likely
return at some point down the line
because lady johanna's task is essential
to the overall story in 1794 dream calls
in a favor constantine owes him and asks
that she rescue his son orpheus
morpheus's son was ripped apart at one
point but being immortal continued
living only as a head he was ultimately
buried in a pile of corpses from the
french revolution johanna finds
orpheus's head and returns it to
morpheus completing her task after their
deal is done lady constantine goes on
with the rest of her life keeping her
family name going so that one day john
constantine could be born lady johanna
died at the age of 99 and dream had her
body and toured near orpheus's temple on
the island of naxos
in the fifth episode 24 7 the character
judy is introduced as a woman concerned
over the state of her relationship with
her partner donna judy admits to hitting
donna during a tumultuous fight and all
indications suggest their time together
is at an end the episode becomes a
nightmare wrought by dream's ruby and
donna is mentioned throughout the
episode in episode 7 the corinthian
picks up a photograph of judy and rose
walker's apartment showing that the two
know each other that's the only
reference tying the two together but far
more is revealed in the comics donna's
full name is donna kavanagh and she
doesn't make her first appearance until
the issue slaughter on 5th avenue during
the a game of view storyline donna's
backstory is expanded to explain her
relationship with judy after judy's
death she started going by the name
foxglove which she used in her
singer-songwriter career she's one of
the people living with barbie in new
york city and she ventures into her
dream to help rescue barbie from the
cuckoo
dream ventures into hell with as much
respect for lucifer as possible but
things don't work out quite as intended
he manages to embarrass lucifer and hell
in front of every demon which doesn't
sit well with the morningstar after
dream leaves lucifer promises to do
something unprecedented that will make
god angry and complete her ultimate goal
if things play out as they did in the
comics lucifer's plan is well known in
the book stream returns to hell to
forgive nada but he finds the realm
empty only lucifer remains searching for
any lost souls or demons remaining in
damnation lucifer explains that it was
time to quit being the lord of hell and
is ready for retirement dream helps to
cut off lucifer's wings and is left
holding the key to hell but this was
lucifer's plan the saddle dream of the
burden of damnation lucifer explains
that it was dream who provided the
impetus to abdicate handing dream the
key lucifer reminds him of the erstwhile
vow to destroy the dreamlord explaining
perhaps it will destroy you and perhaps
it won't but i doubt it will make your
life any easier
the sandman comics go into detail
regarding the nature of the endless who
they are and what they do the netflix
series only offers a glimpse of the
endless with depictions of dream death
desire and despair the endless are the
personification of the concepts the
siblings are named after the endless are
the masters of their own domains and
dreams is called the dreaming there are
others each member of the family rules
over though dreams is the one most often
visited by sentient beings most everyone
meets death but that happens only once
while those who sleep spend a third of
their lives in dreams realm making him
incredibly powerful each member of the
endless has a gallery within the realm
it's from the gallery that they contact
one another by holding their siblings
sigil and asking for an audience only
destiny can compel his siblings to a
meaning whereas the rest must make a
request the family consists of seven
members in addition to dream death
desire despair and destiny there's
delirium and destruction if you pay
attention to the galleries in the show
you'll notice one portrait remains empty
at several points throughout the first
season of the sandman various members of
the endless mention someone they call
the prodigal
it's never explained who they're
referring to but it's something you can
figure out whether you've read the
comics or not the name itself is a clue
as prodigal means a son or daughter who
abandons his familial obligations to set
out on their own knowing this and seeing
an empty portrait in dream and desires
galleries it's clear the prodigal is one
of the endless the comics reveal that
the prodigal is destruction who goes by
the name olethros he's the only member
of the family to abandon his post
leaving his responsibilities behind this
is why the endless refer to him as
prodigal and it's also why his portrait
doesn't hold a sigil in anyone's
galleries
[Music]
oh
him
no no he's still missing
destruction's purpose is to destroy so
new things can be created but he
abandoned his responsibilities when
mankind turned towards science knowing
humanity would make new and horrific
means of destruction destruction opted
to walk away which he did sometime in
the 17th century he fell off his
siblings radars and traveled with a
talking dog named barnabas he ultimately
turns up again but his convictions never
change
at the end of season 1 rose leaves the
dreaming she awakens to learn that her
friend lyda has given birth to a son she
meets the baby but the child doesn't
have a name of course the comics spell
it all out and the child is incredibly
important to the story and dreams fate
the boy is named daniel hall and as you
probably remember from the show dream
insists the baby is his this doesn't sit
well with rose or lida but it's not
expanded upon leaving many wondering
what he's talking about daniel was
created inside the dreaming making him
part of dream's domain he's the son of
hector hall who in the comics is known
as dr fate and lida but he's destined
for something more dream is the one who
names lyda's son daniel which she likes
despite dream's claim on the child it
doesn't take long for daniel to manifest
an ability to enter the dreaming in a
manner far more lucid than most dreamers
ultimately lida loses her sanity and
seeks out the furies to exact their form
of justice on dream the furious
destroyed dream for killing orpheus
though he granted his son a peaceful end
this in turn leaves the role of
dreamlord open soon after daniel
artificially ages and becomes the new
manifestation of dream
[Music]